what if your tv show was tanking and you  lost more than half your viewers since  january  do you think that would be exactly the  moment to  re-release your book on the basis of  evidence that people love you so much  they're going to  buy it probably not  but if you work at cnn if you're a  squeaky little guy who hosts a  media show on cnn you might just try it  and if you did what would happen well  you might sell just 2  000 copies in the entire first week  that book currently ranks 4 007  on the bestseller list there are many  how-to manuals having to do with hvac or  hanging drywall or insulation  that are outselling that book  by the way we don't mean to be mean or  anything it's just if  all signs point to one conclusion  get out of media immediately get out of  media  maybe it's time to get out of media hey  sean hannity here hey  click here to subscribe to fox news  youtube page  and catch our hottest interviews and  most compelling analysis  you will not get it anywhere else